gunners mi vede e si può di bada poco
ben fans devi stare zitta [ __ ] sto
caricando il mio saluto iniziale non mi
disturbare quello a tutti i ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo video sono felice
oggi siamo tornati sugli under simulator
che gioia allora fermi un attimo
siccome sono due volte di fila che prova
a fare questa merda e non riesco ho
deciso stavolta di provare le missioni
però fare un'altra cosa visto che c'è
non va un cazzo ah ok ho sbagliato io il
tasso prof non riesco neanche ad aprire
il menu principale come faccio a finire
una missione design mission allora
proviamo a fare questa cosa proviamo a
fare il design noi della missione mi
avete consigliato di fare così perché
faccio un po cagare e non ci avete mica
tutti i torti e aggiunto bisogna
scegliere chi uccidere allora io una
china o con eroina tameni vediamo se c'è
una che mi sta particolarmente in culo a
far uccidere un maschio abou doma
asciutta ragazzi budo ma stava bene devi
trovare una chiave sbloccare la
cassaforte e rubare i documenti da essa
va bene devi uccidere bersaglio
indossando la divisa di scuola va bè
quello sì anche questo catherine blog
come quello che mi fotte non passare
sotto il metal detector con un'arma
quali metaldetector va bene prima di
concludere ragazzi nemesis condition
questione ministri sconnessa ho
sbagliato e cliccare cazzo c'era scritto
che sarò in seguito perché in seguito
kick ass e la mia nemesi
secondo me i ragazzi con il mio modesto
parere questa partita andrà peggio delle
altre molto peggio e me la sono fatta io
questa cosa triste io comunque ragazzi a
parte le scarpe nell'armadietto andrei a
vedere se riesco a trovare pezzi di
merda ma deve veramente
e tutto questo chi è che mi segue
scusatemi che non ho capito club
dell'occulto
mi scusi signora una donna che te devo
niente sto cercando un coltello scusi
scusi non si offenda ciao zia mimi
prestereste tipo un peso va bene va bene
a questa è un'arma posso ammazzare la
gente con i pesi ho visto l'ultima volta
su cosa ma e col peso posso passare
sotto il metal detector tanto se mi
beccano di questa facendo così c'è una
roba di sopra ragazzi l'ho vista a
signori che gioia questo videogame posso
vedere sotto le gonne
attraverso i muri fini finissimo dove il
tizio o eccolo ma su che gli arti
marziali per caso
si fa qui a parte questo di vedere che
cos'è quella roba da che cazzo è rega
veleno c'è il veleno in questo è di me
lo dici adesso niente ragazzi allora
mista che dobbiamo aspettare che il tipo
però cos'è sta roba di che devo trovare
una chiave per sbloccare la cassaforte
che cassaforte porca vacca complimenti
ma su cast ai pro facendo un gran lavoro
le arti marziali non ti temono dove
ragazzi ma su ca sta uscendo se si reca
qua da solo potete andare dall'altra
parte voi tutti di qua dovete venire va
a fan culo cia ma su ca ti ammazzo sta
andando veramente di sopra è un [ __ ]
porca tra cosa fa
che cazzo è successo lo strozzato sul
capezzolo ed è morto e poi è saltato giù
dalle scale seno è morto perché è caduto
dalle scale non per altro però vabbè che
cazzo è porca [ __ ] cosa mi sono cagato
addosso da asp e famiglie del replay non
hanno capito share e play no cioè ho
visto ho visto allora ebrei che ci ri
gioco che ho visto sta tipa che è
passata sopra mamma su ca nun la cagato
di striscio si avvicina e lentissimo e
mi ammazza cosa non ho capito a era quel
dio mi sono ricordato adesso era quella
che mi doveva
a inseguire quindi c'è una tipa che ti
segue lentamente e poi ti ammazza ok bel
bello perché io ho messo questo
dettaglio nelle missioni non potevo
toglierlo che già è difficile così ci
manca solo questo proprio non riesco a
prendere mazzuca prima che vada di sopra
tanto ormai sappiamo dove va quindi
andiamo distrutto starmi fermi fermi
fermi cazzo mi sono persi tutti per
brutta brutta ma chi è questa ma è lei
che mi se io entro quati pò ed esco di
qua si sia proprio lei che tenta di chi
cazzo è buono e corre c'è il passo
svelto ragazzi pure ragazzi la cosa più
ansiolitica che io abbia mai visto in un
videogame orribile sembra un film che ho
visto tratto recentemente è anche pelata
pure claudio bisio
non so se funziona ma proviamoci pam ha
funzionato
porca [ __ ] soffrire le porte peccato
dov'è andato a mazzuca in tutto questo
eccolo ma solca vieni qua muoviti
porca vacca dov'è andato [ __ ]
sapevo ma tu hai avaya lezione con la
fascia di arti marziali ma scusa niente
ragazzi aspettiamo che passi il tempo fa
ancora ci ha mica gi c'è una tipa che
vuole uccidermi perché va bene non ho
ben capito un questa roba della tipa
però mentre cio lezione spero non mi
tocchi almeno qua ascolta ma su chi no
che è così lo tengo fermo
vediamo se riesco ad ammazzarlo
decentemente stavolta è un'altra
abitazione guarda stavo andando in
palestra
fatti i cazzi tuoi great un cazzo te ne
vai con quel davanzale lì e non sei in
balcone non posso ammazzare ok
adesso ma mica che botta in faccia
feroce corri prima che arrivi se perché
si riprende mentre cielo in braccio che
succede ok ragazzi ci siamo fermi che
scarpe di merda size fammi capire è
stato visto a ok si vede che i guai
destra c'era qualcuno [ __ ]
controllato va bene allora niente è
difficile
proviamo a cambiare un paio di settaggi
e vedere se cambia qualcosa perché mi
chiamo fatta più difficile di prima high
school pleasure of che subire o phone
posso anche decidere di togliere la
gente che sta in scuola la quale la
difficoltà scusami casa finisce un
prefetto e good luck un paio di seghe
allora ragazzi l'atp ma da novanta gente
ce l'ha così a soli 100 c'è ma non ho
capito cliccato io qualcosa
quanta come files c così tanta gente
scusate se c'era la metà della metà
della mega e cazzo è uno stadio facetime
orge madonna che il casinò in tutto
questo la tipa la zia ha già vedere una
gara quella che sarà seduta prima li che
[ __ ] non ci ho fatto caso c'è
l'ammazzo adesso subito crepa [ __ ]
ok ma devo portarla via la portò via vai
vai portati a portare a se per caso
incontro qualcuno
porca [ __ ] che mi sto salvato merda
come faccia controlli dietro gli angoli
perfetto ai live e ne va e veloce se per
qualcuno sono morta carri open
ora che non ci voglio credere ce la sto
facendo impossibile luridi prezzi gli
stronzi stavolta non me l'ha fatta e
questa la prendiamo e la mettiamo qua
dietro primo e stai qua ferma non ti
denudare non ti muovere come stai
facendo adesso stai ferma ora andiamo a
lavarci visto che c'è questo piccolo
problema o dio ragazzi per una volta
nella vita forse non voglio parlare
prima che che c'era il sangue sul muro
scazzi successo era già lì e non lo
tocco quel ok
prendi i vestiti sporchi e li vado a
buttare nell'inceneritore perfetto
ok ragazzi ci siamo allora ho portato
tutto lì tra due minuti esatti quindi
adesso dovrebbero spostarsi tutti perché
dovrebbero in teoria per elezione giusto
che mi fa passare il tempo perché non
passa il tempo
starting porca eva vabbè dai tanto manca
un minuto quindi almeno quello otto sono
le otto lezione ma voi fate qualcosa
nella vostra caso di vita inutile posso
portare lo stesso i vestiti a buttar lì
si meno male perché se non sapevo come
fare ragazzi perfetto anche il peso
pieno di sangue lo porta
[Musica]
questo potrebbe essere un problema ma
niente ragazzi allora per passare veloce
il tempo l'unica roba che mi è rimasta
andare in classe
fare lezione l'unica perché sennò col
cazzo che passa il tempo tanto sto
facendo elezioni in tutta la ginnastica
però vabbè io mi sono rotto il cazzo
dopo il cazzo e basta cioè io con questa
questa è l'ultima che sarà l'ultima
l'ultimo che facciano per tutti voglio
più toccare questo gioco di merda questo
gioco in mano voglio più toccare non
tocco non lo facciano lo vedono lo
guardo nuovo d'oro non lo sento
[ __ ] qual è il problema ho fatto
tutto quello che dovevo fare sono andato
a lezione la polizia arrivata perché chi
è che mi ha scoperto nessuno è arrivata
così la polizia arriva a cui siamo
arrivati un morto e colpa sua
va bè ragazzi conclude episodi gli under
io sono un fallimento questo videogioco
un fallimento è niente ragazzi però che
vi sia piaciuto ciò però la danesi una
volta a [ __ ] i pesi che servono per
strozzare la gente sul capezzolo e basta
però bravi di sempre 100 ragazzi cosa
invece che al momento è un mi piace
anche i vari social che come i dotare
iscrizione e ci sono i fischietti dici
mi chiamano possiamo vito bella ragazzi